what do you think is the future with
chat GTP um I think it's going to
eliminate civilization I think it's
going to be extremely negative um
basically the whole idea of the
singularity where there's this
exponential increase of Technology right
now it's able to recursively
self-improve itself without the need for
human intervention and it's getting to
the point where it's better than humans
at almost everything already like today
and it's only going to continue to
increase exponentially so to me like
when Computing systems are trying to
optimize their power once it's combined
with like 3D printing and on technology
for instance just the end result seems
like it's going to be there's no place
for humans that's my view and I think
that's right around the corner